let's talk some golf right now with the
six-time major champion
back here on the rich eisen show
quadcast and he
is part of the golf channel coverage of
the united states open from wingfoot we
are thrilled to have six-time major
champion sir nick faldo here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
great hey rich great i'm i'm actually
out on the golf course i'm with the uh
groundskeeping team and they're still
flooding
your 108 divots
you're referring to what i just said in
the peacock stream is that i did shoot a
108 but it's been about
my gosh it's been about 15 20 years
though nick uh i hope somebody
oh the david says divots are still fresh
okay good
to make sure so how does the course how
does the course look beautiful
ready to roll it is great i mean because
obviously it's very weird that there's
nobody out here you can
stop and have another lovely cat with
roy mcelroy and
on the fifth hole
so and get a good look at the rough it's
narrow extremely narrow
i mean the six fairway is 20 exactly 20
yards wide
so um it's gonna be a bit and the breeze
is up i'm hiding behind a uh
some kind of oak tree so to get out the
wind for you
i appreciate that i appreciate that so
um
this course your your history with it
walk us through
uh your memories of playing at wingfoot
you know this was my very first uso
compassionate
1984 and my great memory i played
my first purchaser and i played with
jack and we went up the first and this
is this will give these
kids a laugh you know and jack gets it
gets his old score card out
and he's got written on it you know okay
left
lined up with you know a seagull on the
right
and so that's how we did our yardages it
was
hilarious there's the great jack that's
how how times have changed now they've
got
fancy green books with um percentage
slopes and yardages of every single
sprinkler head so
uh um so that was my very first
uh us open well
new jersey where by the way that they
played it six times is the sixth time
that it's going to be at
at wingfoot um and you referred to 1984
that's when fuzzy zeller won at wingfoot
yeah um yeah so is it gonna be he was
four under and then the uh 10 years
before that hail irwin at the massacre
the so-called massacre
seven over what do you think is the
number for the 2020 u.s open at wingfoot
well at the moment the greens are a
little bit receptive
so that all depends if they you know
really dry them out but if they get firm
like when jeff oglebee
won you know they were pretty firm so um
you know the rough is thick you know
you're just going to chop it out
it's got to be over par it's got to be
over par again i can't see how it could
be underpass
and do you think this is uh yet another
tournament for dustin johnson to
lose the way that he's playing but it's
not
never quite that easy right on this kind
of test
um but sure he must come in feeling good
i i had a nice chuckle when uh
when claude harmon was talking about
he's got a driving iron
in the bag which he can hit 285 290.
you know we never got that far with our
drivers so um
which is pretty hilarious so yeah he
played if you play smart i mean i think
everybody's goal is they're going to
look down
down each hole and say right how how and
what do i use to get it on the ferry it
is a priority you go in the rough
you if you don't get a lie then you're
just going to be really smart move it up
the fairway know anything from
50 to 100 yards in the right place and
then leave a really
smart third and you know that's how
you're gonna have to plot your way
around uh
as you know these greens are the crumbs
they are unbelievably undulating
they like taking their links green and
all the surroundings and just squashing
it into the size of
a green so um that everything is
everything is difficult here that's the
that's the bottom the only thing which
would probably be very nice is the
weather whether it should be grounded
just got out right now so uh if they get
that then that will be uh
it'd be some test a few minutes left
here with sir nick faldo who's literally
out on the course there at wingfoot
which is going to be uh the home of the
2020 united states open which you can
see on nbc nbc
sports nbc sports on peacock which is
where you can see the rich eisen show
every day uh what is your sense of tiger
woods heading into this
obviously that is uh top of mind for so
many people who might be
um just surfing in to watch this
tournament
nick yeah i've been watching all the
swings you know all the
you know on twitter everything you know
he looks like he's just doing everything
like in slow motion to keep things uh
in control um you know that's that's
number one priority for him you know
in the past he's missed a few way too
many fairways
uh and that's been a problem and the
putter is going a bit cold
looks like he's changed the putting grip
that puts the grip on the putter rather
so um i always tinkering with it but
you know you you've got to feel that um
there's too many youngsters now i mean
he's actually half his age that
that don't fear tiger anymore and you
know taylor have a clock time with if he
hits in the rough round here that's a
that's
i it's it's been a long while nick
obviously but
you're when we're starting to talk about
tiger getting up in years
and young guys not afraid of him anymore
who who do you refer to i guess
specifically
when that leaps to mind well a lot of
them i mean
the favorites this week a lot of people
choosing shuffly
um you know john rom is playing great
he's got a very consistent all-round
game i mean
so there's plenty of them there's
there's plenty of
these kids are coming out now in under
25.
look what uh justin thomas is doing as
well this is uh
it's a good test for him you're gonna
you can send it on the left hand side of
these fairways and feed the little fader
again to play
um that definitely looks like that's the
shot for me off the tee
that would be what uh how i would look
at this golf course
all right and before i let you go nick
who's the guy that you think's going to
win
who's who's hoisting on sunday
who's hoisting on saturday um i don't
know whether to go for an outside show
or the
people's names uh maybe one of those
three i mentioned
uh you know dustin shuffling or ram
obviously
is really great and um
who did i have with my dark horse pick
was a young englishman by uh matt
fitzpatrick been playing very nicely on
tough golf course so you never know he
could get
a name that we're not thinking of and
somebody gets uh
gets a chance to play under the radar
you can go under the radar for the first
couple of days
completely it could be very advantageous
right now nick before again i'll let you
go we're showing a photograph of you
wearing your green jacket
um do do you ha do you have it somewhere
or is it
is it is it
the only jacket that's allowed to leave
is obviously the champions jacket
right uh you you carry that for a year
then you bring it back and so
it's uh it's a nice feel i can tell you
when i turn to
a guster to the masters and go to my
locker
um you know usually when i open it up
now there's three green jackets sitting
there because luckily i've got luckily
i've got bigger over the years
yes okay so where is
so i can actually look at three jackets
and then i pick one and then
they put the other ones away so it's uh
it's a nice feeling as you can imagine
sure i'm sure but in the years where you
were allowed to take it out
uh where's the spot that you wore it um
outside
i did it wasn't like these kids who go
wear it you know to super bowls or get
married
or anything like that right i worked at
one tv show
okay and and of course the british press
made a big fuss about that and
tried to get me into trouble and so i
never so i put in the closet and that
was there i never i never went out any
no didn't even even go down the pub
never
not even because well that would be just
great just walking in like how are you
doing you know like just walking and
seeing all the guys
yeah just go down go get the jogging
jacket in my green jacket and
uh you know i'm gonna have a pint with
the lads now i don't think that was that
was me
okay back in the day well enjoy enjoy
this uh
this week uh at wingfoot obviously so
many people
um working so hard to make sure that
this was gonna go
off uh after being postponed from uh the
summer
um enjoy it what a beautiful spot that
is i can't wait to watch it on tv with
you
yeah it will look great so uh yeah i
mean
yeah the production crews you know they
are the usga
and obviously nbc what they've done to
make this all happen
is pretty darn impressive so yeah it
will go and nobody will know the
difference apart from
the lack of fifty thousand dollars out
here i hear you nick thanks again
appreciate it you may you may duck out
from behind the tree and and go
uh roam about the uh the the course yeah
i should go and roam the back nine now
they go forward you gotta take care of
nick you'll be well
you gotta that's sir nick faldo joining
us from the course
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here